when I tell people that I'm trying to
develop a contraceptive pill for men the
response usually varies along gender
lines women say something like fantastic
it's about time when men have one of two
responses they either love the idea or
they look at me a little warily and
wonder what exactly I have in store for
their testicles so why does the world
need a male pill well what if I told you
that of the six million pregnancies
annually in the United States 3 million
of them are unintended that's half
that's a really surprising number and
those 3 million unintended pregnancies
account for the vast majority of the
more than 1 million abortions annually
performed the United States happily the
rate of unintended pregnancy has fallen
in the last few years by about 10
percent this is because more women are
using effective long-acting reversible
forms of contraception but we still have
a long way to go one approach that's
finally becoming a real possibility is
better contraceptive options for men
think about it we have over a dozen
methods of contraception for women pills
patches IUDs shots sponges rings etc for
men we've had the same two options for
more than a hundred years condoms and
vasectomy despite having only two
options both of which have significant
drawbacks men currently account for 30%
of all contraceptive use with 10% of
couples relying on vasectomy and 20% of
couples using condoms why are twenty
percent of couples relying on condoms
for contraception
when condoms have a one-year failure
rate of over 15% it's because many women
can't either safely take currently
available female contraceptives for
reasons such as blood clots or they
can't tolerate the side effects so if
you think a male contraceptive would be
useful the next question is how do we go
about developing one well there's two
general approaches the first approach is
to try and interfere with the way the
sperm swim towards or bind to the egg
this approach turns out to be really
difficult because it's hard to get
enough medication in the small volume of
the ejaculate and have it still work
inside the female reproductive tract
this is why there's been a lot more work
done on the second approach which is
turning off sperm production entirely
this is also challenging why turns out
that men make a lot of sperm men make a
thousand sperm every second and to have
an effective contraceptive you need to
get that level of sperm production down
to 1% of its normal value the good news
is this is possible almost the most
studied approach has been to use
hormones to suppress sperm production
testosterone and progesterone when
administered together will suppress the
signals from the brain to the test us to
make sperm and in about 90% of men sperm
production after three to four months
will stop unfortunately 10% of men don't
respond to these hormonal regimens for
reasons that aren't understood for the
last several years my colleagues and I
have been taking a different approach to
male contraceptive development one that
doesn't involve the administration of
hormones specifically we are looking to
block the function of vitamin A in the
testes why well for over 90 years it's
been known that you need vitamin A to
make sperm animals who are deprived of
vitamin A in their diet
stop making sperm and restart making
sperm again when the vitamin A is
reintroduced the vitamin A that we
ingest
is converted by a family of enzymes to
something called retinoic acid one of
these enzymes is found only in the
testes it's this enzyme that we are
attempting to block blockade of this
enzyme should deprive the test us of
retinoic acid and stop sperm production
without affecting vitamin a's functions
elsewhere in the body we're testing this
approach in animals and hope to move to
human testing soon obviously the impact
of such a male contraceptive would go
well beyond reproductive biology it's
interesting to speculate about the
effect that would have on relationships
between men and women one intriguing
possibility is that a man could monitor
his contraceptive status over time in
the last several years two groups have
introduced home sperm testing devices
that are iPhone based and that are easy
to use a man could test his sperm count
and share the result with his partner if
the man's sperm count were zero the man
and his partner would be able to feel
very comfortable relying on his
contraceptive a tool like this coupled
with a male contraceptive could greatly
increase the role for men in preventing
unintended pregnancy the researchers who
are working on male contraception are
trying to create a better future for
couples a future where contraception is
no longer considered just a woman's
issue rather an issue for couples to
decide together so why does the world
need a male pill well I believe that a
male pill will help reduce the
stubbornly high rates of unintended
pregnancy and abortion and allow men to
equally participate in contraception
thank you
[Applause]